Amy Schumer look so let me get to the
story did you bet is the story you say
the name is uh okay it happens Amy
Schumer's latest Netflix special dropped
and it has been won starred dropped is
right that's not nice I don't want to
laugh together was one sort as a matter
of fact I didn't want to cover this
story at first because I thought you
know what I would hate it if
conservative trolls just went in one
starter thing because comedy is
subjective I'll never be one to
fact-check jokes but then if you look at
the fan feedback it was it was certainly
not from all right trolls people just
didn't find it funny people thought that
she had really kind of lost her her
group her step and I will say that you
know I've joked about this on the show
I've joked about the several times rest
you know the thing with Amy Schumer
who's been Chelsea Handler's are
basically she's basically Chelsea
Handler delight is when she walks out on
stage you can set your stopwatch until
it's I'm a filthy [ __ ] you can set your
watch on stage and we before you even
knew me I was saying this in West and in
fact he's a little on the podcast so we
this would be what two thousand two
thousand fourteen one email so I've been
saying it to the at least two thousand
twelve when Evan predicting that that
gets old that that really only caters to
a certain subset of people and the older
you get you know that comedy doesn't age
well Kathleen Madigan will always be
funny bill burr Nick DiPaolo it's pretty
diverse if you watch their specials you
know bill burr might be talking about
his wife than his dogs and politics and
he could be talking about stand-up on
the road than a TV show when your entire
acts centers around you being a [ __ ] um
it's not super palatable so I decided to
put wheat we did this so that you don't
have to we decided to watch the Amy
Schumer comedy special in fact with a
stopwatch to see how long it takes for
her to get to that stick and and
determine if this is trolling or people
might actually just find her her act to
be getting old
so you're welcome okay here we go
[Music]
nearly block of swimming right into yoga
for the past year I've gotten very rich
famous and humble here again and maybe
you caught this I don't know who saw
this I tweeted out a photo of myself
wearing just underwear nothing but
underwear okay
what haha right away first bit
what's the time do we know what's the
time Edward or 24 seconds 24 cent you
took that left it is stuck on 24 seconds
no okay all right so 24 seconds right
away she's going into the bit her
underwear bit 24 seconds I know we're
not being super forgiving
no but the what was the rule any
sluttiness letting this flooding in it's
like super dirty over there up I'm a
whole any general horror sniffs men
wouldn't sweat that you're here anywhere
morning Bob along with that well god
those thing bit yes hi Merlin you got a
step for that one how long do we go that
was all the same bit but started over
okay 30 so 32 seconds there's no we're
going to make it through this okay let's
reset the timer getting blackout drunk
tonight the next thing how long was it
ha ha ha ha I was I'm in Hollis thank
you I came as a blackout and there was a
stranger going down on me
okay pause how long 40 40 40 seconds and
all that was set up from the last one
blackout I mean I don't know again I
don't think I'm gonna criticize it's not
really fair because it's a part of the
same bit but it's a new joke yeah just
an important note right away she was
pleading to the men why aren't you
applauding like I said this is so
OneNote it would be unless you're a
woman of that ilk unless you live that
light it's probably not very funny you
know I've never very small parts Sanjiv
women - I've never woken up from a
blackout being blackout drunk period and
I've never woken up from a being
blackout drunk with a guy performing
oral sex on me
so it's not as relatable as say like you
know jerry-san what still there I wanted
odd golly here fool
you're lying break on my well I guess
you should pause now there's gonna be a
joke about it but how long was that how
long are we in Edward the sound guy 107
she's getting it's getting what she's
doing better 107 he's putting it back
problems I don't wanna hit play because
she's about she's about to start talking
about her vagina I don't want to hit
play because I know we have to think we
just got to plow through the darkness to
get to the light the other end of the
tunnel is holding back you know easily
kind of Minority Report your own book
pages but stranger things get in fine
car we do we pause this is this or just
the same bit this is unfortunately
noteworthy okay so how long I want to go
here the entire 27 seconds is pretty
much all yes
so do we not count it recount that time
I mean I don't know when I don't know
when to pause the timer cuz it never
stopped
okay so I was talking about it was
grabbing it with me no lady small
barnyard animal okay okay
is that a different joke let's with the
pause of stopped clock 48 seconds from
transitioning to how large her vagina is
- how bad her vagina smells and this is
the thing it's guys don't a lot of girls
like oh I'm one of the guys guys don't
find this funny no guy this is this is
why you know she's pushing with 3540 guy
don't want to merit that you can be
funny as a girl you can even be somewhat
crass as a girl but no guy is gonna sit
there and watch this but I you know what
I want that to bear my children this is
the nature of it and it's like we're so
married I know some girls are wanting to
let everybody go down on that
yeah okay this is a whole new bit
hahahahahaha second
hey Ross and I would push him off oh no
[Music]
she just went on a eight-minute tangent
how disgusting her vagina is and I was
talking about Damien guy and by
physically assaulting him we're not
funny her vagina absolutely just edible
a good point
that's the feminist angle like I'm so
gross
but you better Baskin my growth nests
otherwise I'm going to push off with it
that's a she wonders why she's single
restart the clock have you ever had a
glass in your mouth and go this is okay
okay what's the time Edward what here to
think it's a theme of I'm such a [ __ ]
I'm so disgusting and then like you said
vilifying guys for first off again this
just makes guys seem like absolute rep
and I get a comedy yeah this guy for my
job would trap trash by think they don't
they don't care at all they just do
whatever they want sexually but then she
just talk about pushing him off a cliff
for not getting out of Regina she's the
guy she accuses all the guys as being
only she's way gross grosser and fatter
in the worst discussion that occurs on
air off air here we don't talk like this
now and if a guy talks this generally
speaking the guy speaks like this
profanely or it makes most other guys
uncomfortable yeah like there's their
suggestion there's okay being dirty
there's being even being profane and
then they're just like complete medical
it's just very off-putting okay well
let's go to the next timer because menu
our recent eight years old feminist
message do you ever stop to consider
that maybe just Amy Schumer has been
surrounded by horrible people her whole
life like men are raised that your
aren't raised to hate yourself did her
parents raise her to hate herself does
every guy that she knows think that
everything he does is a miracle because
I don't know I really don't know anyone
like the people she's describing she's
raised at a Greyhound bus station by
bystanders to meet there would you skim
through a little bit the timeline there
alright just make sure this isn't just
just as the first you know like it make
sure it's not just the first ten minutes
alright so we're at ten minutes and 55
seconds I'm going to skim through now
and I'm casting it with my phone so all
right no more timer we don't need timer
ever the sound guy let's just see we're
going to skim - I'm going to skip ahead
here seven minutes something that's
still going
so the longest time I think we had was
still under two minutes and now we've
gone through 17 minutes still there
let's go let's go forward 29 minutes in
doesn't know how to do to blow dogs with
me 29 that's n she's literally
pantomiming a [ __ ] that's 29 minutes
in we're trying to be fair this is this
is past the with midway point of the
special and she's still doing it still
isn't all about that all right let's go
uh let's go 40 minutes in so she's
talking about the Second Amendment how
blind people can buy gun I would love it
can we just ignore enough people are
laughing as much as two mentally ill
terrorists or blind and beetle I love my
whole life they're given and her
political [ __ ] a guns there's only 15
minutes left in this special he spends
more and there's not been a single ten
eight six minutes span of it not being
about her being of sulfur disgusting
[ __ ] if you notice her audience that's
the only time they know the loss of this
point they'd be conditioned the only
laugh that you're like that you're like
I don't know about Second Amendment some
are you've been having sex with animals
quite last clap clap clap again should
every right to do this comedy and I full
license to come and I'm not that's what
I want to go to the political discussion
about her being inaccurate because it's
a joke
we're simply talking about you know she
goes out and she does this absolute this
victim lining of people not liking her
in the one I thought the one minute bit
was like trolling the one star I think
it's clearly organic because I think
it's just the general person is on
Netflix who isn't Amy Schumer management
turn this on and it just not like it no
no no woman I know associate myself with
replying this entertaining as a woman
certainly not for an hour even people
who aren't politically active
politically minded and a lot for the
feminism a lot of the women
new thought trainwreck was funny to an
extent yeah because all these like
orgeous girls are around but foaming at
the mouth is like oh let me in that
school and all right okay there's been
the entire special the entire special
has been either we're good right we're
good the entire special has been set
your stopwatch less than a minute less
than them two minutes without
exaggerating at any given point I'm
super [ __ ] look at all the bad words I
can say look how much dirtier I can be
than a guy and feminism yeah so explain
what makes a difference then say a Jim
Gaffigan who seems maybe possibly one
note about being fatty McDonald's why is
this different well first off I don't
think Jim I know you feel that way I
don't think Jim Gaffigan is that one
note because he had a lot of he has a
lot of material on his wife his children
his traveling going to Israel is a long
bit about that I think he just most
famous for his fat material sure ah so I
think if you look at the catalogue of
Jim Gaffigan is life you remove the food
stuff it's smaller but he's so immature
I think with her you remove the [ __ ]
feminist stuff you have no act first off
and then even if it were more OneNote
every guy and almost every woman can
relate to late at night bad decisions
you know hot pockets or whatever it is
he talks about now socket Netflix in hot
pockets or even the McDonald's
drive-through everyone can relate to
that to some level to some degree and
he's family-friendly
so people are at least willing to give
him some leeway because like okay you
know my kids can watch him joke about
hot pockets and Lean Cuisine so how long
now that the special has been released
and it got one stars one start and pan
how long until Amy Schumer said the bet
because that's because she's a woman are
you smell very funny I just chicken to
know how much from the owners point all
right we do this we watch the Amy
Schumer special we went through it you
can follow along with us look at the
time codes so that you don't have to and
the only reason we did this was to
remove the shame from your life you do
not need to feel ashamed any longer
we're not thinking Amy Schumer's funny
it's okay
you're not alone hey if you like this
clip you're like most of the Internet
you have a short attention span but it
was taken from the full show you can see
it in the Box playing next to me that's
once a week on Thursdays full one and a
half hour show or you can join the Mudd
Club for the daily show let's take some
of that off YouTube because they're
monitoring us and censoring her words